i was not going to be able to do baby
driver because i was locked into this
third series of from dusto dawn and
robert
knew that it was so important to me that
he rewrote the third season
to get me out of the third season more
so i could go do that movie
so honestly what i keep on saying is
like robert rodriguez is just
a legend he is the best if it wouldn't
have been for him
it wouldn't have happened probably and
in every shape or form he brought me
here he believed in me he allowed me and
enabled me to go do that job
so then alita padalanja came around but
i knew about elita for a long time
because i've been working with him for
so long he was so excited he kept on
showing us all about elita
we heard when he james had just let him
know that he was going to do a leader we
were there you know we were a family
worked three years together
and i never thought you know i heard a
lot about elita but i never thought
there was something for me
also i was also an unknown actress and
the cast was really
you know massive and i remember he
called me he said
i have this very small role in elita
battle angel but it's really cool and i
think you would do such a good job
and he's like but here's the gist you
have to audition for it james does not
let anyone be in the movie unless they
get audition and he sees them
so i was like okay let's do it i'll
audition i'm always game to audition i
like
love auditioning i've i i've learned to
love it because
it also allows me to feel like i earned
something um it's nice to get offers but
it's it's game you know it's game time
for me
and so i did and i auditioned and
james eventually liked it and
he gave me his seal of approval and i
went to set
and then james tried to make my role
bigger because he really liked
what we had done so we try to like
stretch it as much as possible
but i was i mean i always i never
stopped geeking out i was like i'm with
christoph waltz what's happening like
i'm licking crystal fault's face what is
happening like it was so crazy
and it was so fun to do that job because
it was also the rise of rosa salazar at
the moment and i was so excited to see
her she's so hard working and such a
strong
woman with like a vision and a clarity
and such a good actress and she tackled
this so
beautifully so but it was nice because i
went back to my crew it was
all my crew for three years so then it
was just like going back home with my
best friends it was very cool
you